bienvenue dans paf l'émission discuter
on débat de l'actualité de la semaine on
débattra donc il fait ce qui a fait la
une de l'actualité
les taxis contre hubert gilbert contre
les taxis hubert pop en tout cas contre
des taxis on parlera peut-être de savoir
s'il faut que n'y ait plus d'élus à
partir de 70 ans il faut légaliser le
cannabis comme le demande le conseil
économique et social
on parla évidemment puisqu'on est
vendredi après midi que cette émission
est en jeu ce vendredi après-midi de la
totale qui vient d'être commis dans
l'isère pour en parler stéphane manceau
de l'usb est ce qu qu'initie université
versailles saint quentin c'est ça dans
leurs droits il vaut mieux mettre dans
leur partition ça peut prêter à
confusion avec regret dumas vous de
faire ça hit man et the strange luke
madec des templiers à leur financement
d'une ampleur absolument phénoménale or
le super u
on en parlera dans quelques classes
moustapha bâ oui bonjour bonjour a pas
très sain voilà du club de foot de
trappes et de toutes les façons si non
c'est pas tout à fait mûr de presse
segura namani brillé mais la cause de la
chaleur permet aussi dans ses études il
vous fait est en train de finir
gestuellement palestine ce qu'ils y
c'est le bruit qui période d'examen leur
espérons que les résultats soient à la
hauteur de ce qu'il dit ils seront
mérité oui absolument
j'y travaille sérieusement c'est en tout
cas le bruit qu'ils font dans tout
buvait est ce que j'ai fait ils ont
certes la joie dit bonjour aux éditeurs
avec deux nouveaux romans policiers mais
pas que comme des triplets de jean-luc
ou cocher le montre et en main propre
des jérôme eulma ont en en gros en amour
alors en main propre cette histoire d'un
clerc de notaire d'origine c'est un
beurre un beurre clerc de notaire qui
travaillaient avignon ou en avignon
jamais ce qu'il faut dire et il est
obligé de repartir en algérie pour aller
réaliser une succession et ça se fasse
aussi bien que prévu le frère mustapha
ben voilà mais il y pas beaucoup il y
traque et replay des replays cochet
c'est un roman assez amusant parce que
c'est une équipe de cinéma américain qui
pour des raisons syndicales
aux etats unis se dit qu'il faut
absolument qu'il finisse un film qu'ils
ont commencé aux états unis ils vont le
finir en france et il trouve car tarbes
ont tardé guison peu trompeuse déguisé
tarbes et sa région en une
une contrée du middle west mais c'est
vrai ils vont vraiment leur arriver tard
ben voilà les bons vraiment très
américaine ils ont vraiment tourner ce
film comme si à tarbes comme si c'était
aux états unis et puis on parlera
peut-être de zhuhai publiée à quelques
mois de deux lignes d'easynet en ligne
qui s'appelle être toxiques sont des
dessins tout à fait réjouissant sur les
taxis et qui résume bien la situation
d'aujourd'hui on va peut-être commencer
par cet attentat qu'on a appris ce matin
qui s'est déroulée donc dans le désert
attente alors et avec deux choses qui
semblent assez intéressante donc dans
cet attentat le premier c'est que
d'abord on arrêtait la personne qui est
présumé avoir commis enfin qu'il faut
vraisemblement c'est lui qui a commis
cet attentat donc on va peut-être en
savoir un petit peu sur son parcours
on sait que c'est quelqu'un qui avait
été repérée déjà par la police dans les
années 2005 2006 qui n'était plus figé
depuis 2008 mais que c'est un salafiste
et c'est visiblement une personne isolée
qui connaissait bien les lieux
et puis il ya ce symbole c'est à dire
cette décapitation puis la tête de la
personne qui a décapité qui a été
accrochée à la grille de l'usiné dans
laquelle nul de laquelle il attend ta
sueur sur ces deux faits c'est dire
isolement donc difficile difficultés de
de repérer les gens qui vont faire des
attentats
et puis le symbole n'est ce que quelques
mois the same d'abord curieux fin mais
peut-être que florence nous en dira plus
mais ça bizarre qu'on fiche des gens
puis après on les défis sur le type on
sait qu on sait qu'il a été fiché villes
les plus tous un peu curieuse c'est un
casier judiciaire ça reste un peu donc
là on n'y a pas de case il alors à quoi
sert ces fiches 6 ou 6 bout de deux ans
du brulhois je crois qu'on peut pas
suivre tout le monde parce que ça
demande énormément de devrait enfin
concessions sont avec eux il faudrait à
peu près une vingtaine de deux policiers
pour suivre quelqu'un à plein temps oui
c'est à dire à richard après charlie
hebdo ou saas et maintenance
c'est peut-être un peu exagéré mais
sinon l'autre chose vraiment troublant
ce qui terrorise c'était le but cela dit
mais c'est le côté pieds nickelés de ces
gens là parce qu'on a l'impression
qu'ils se sont même plus des vrais 2 2
de gros professionnels qui n'ont ses
salles à peu près n'importe qui
n'importe quel abruti n'importe quel
type un peu un peu sous la férule de
l'islamisme radical qui se dit tiens
j'ai une idée je vais rentrer comme ça
j'ai essayé de faire péter des bonbonnes
de gaz dans une usine en défonçant la
porte avec une voiture ridicule c'est
cette erreur c'est vraiment terrorisme
on se dit ils sont prêts à tout mais
avec doigt avec un amateurisme qui
effectivement au meurtrier mais qui moi
m'angoisse encore beaucoup plus concédé
et cet habitant du fait que celle de
plus en plus difficile et qu'on arrive à
pas vers un possible à regret c'est oui
enfin on écoute un jean charles je me
dis c'est c'est bien ça qu'on appelle le
terrorisme d'ailleurs dans un coin qui
surgit de nulle part et qui fait ce
qu'il peut pour sauver un arbre pour
faire mal c'est pas une armée alors la
france est en guerre
les pinces et c'est terrible c'est une
espèce de guerre sur l'oise assez
épouvantable alors là on franchit encore
un cran si tant est qu'on puisse le
faire dans le revers avec le symbole
donc oui c'est un vrai talent
enfin j'ai envie que non c'est ça qui
nous a frappés on est dans le film
d'horreur absolue
alors moi je sais je suis comme vous je
n'ai que les informations qui y ont été
enregistrés en et vendre l'après midi
donc on ne possède pas en tout les
pouvoirs qu'on voit les les images d'un
film d'horreur
on se demande ce que ce qu'il ya dans la
tête de ces gens mais en même temps on
se demande qui les manipulent on se
demande pourquoi maintenant il vous a
pas échappé quand même temps il ya eu un
attentat à ces horribles
en tunisie ou sur une plage gladiator un
fou à tirer à l'armé de guerre sur deux
braves vacanciers qui étaient là pour
profiter de la vie et du soleil tunisien
donc on se dit mais que se passe-t-il
qu'est ce qu'il y a dans la tête de ces
gens qui manipulent ces individus qui
leur donne le top départ et n'a plus que
quelques mois pour ça c'est pas sûr du
tout bon écoutez on va t'attendre que
nous ayons des informations plus
précises sur le sujet en tout cas
effectivement le symbole est absolument
épouvantable on est à des années
lumières de la civilisation donc voie
après c'est trop compliqué de
stigmatiser untel ou untel a évidemment
et musulmans mon corps est de montrer du
doigt ce qui est absolument abominable
en même temps c'est ce qui se passe sur
la planète on sait que death l'état
islamique boko haram tout ça font
beaucoup parler d'eux en ce moment et là
d'un seul coup encore une fois on va
laisser émerger un événement majeur qui
bien entendu nous met les nerfs à fleur
de peau les uns les autres et du coup
nous oublions un certain nombre de
problématiques pourtant importante de la
société
nous avions hier et aujourd'hui le
problème de dubert et des taxis mais en
fait on parle depuis longtemps devant ma
réalisation mais oui mais justement
c'est tout à fait incroyable qui a des
moments où d'un seul coup la société se
réveille avec des soubresauts hop tout
de suite on met en place une espèce de
de terreur qui fait qu' on oublie le
reste je ne sais pas s'il ya de la
manipulation j'espère que non mais en
même temps on n'y a pas grand manitou
mais il ya probablement des oppositions
de
d'influents ce qu'ils font que parfois
le fait de nous envoyer comme ça d
affaire horrible qui sont très proches
du film d'horreur nous permettent
d'oublier le reste j'ai quand même le
sentiment parfois qu'il ya de la
manipulation de avorter d'autres et ça
m'inquiète ça m'a inquiété devant on est
là pour le dire moi je dis ça mais la
quête d'un kg et de la manipulation qui
du symbole je veux bien inquiet de la
manipulation pour dire on va pas parler
d'autre chose pendant lequel ces
attentats ça me paraît un peu moins bras
prévient place pas cet avis en tout cas
florence sont pas allés sur la lune mais
oui ou non non non non non mon tout
raccourci est pas bon et caricatural non
non non non j'ai pas dit que les
américains sont pas allés sur la lune
jeunes qu'elle n'avait pas inventé le
feu
pas plus que j'ai dit que les martiens
été sur la planète il ya cinq mille cinq
cents ans
non non non non je dis simplement que
healy a parfois des relations entre un
événement et un autre qui sont
inquiétantes
voilà c'est tout ce que je dis florence
martel est choqué ceux ci avaient une
chute de ses déclarations là parce que
tu ne les partage pas tout à fait ce qui
est inquiétant oui si c'est juste le
terrorisme
je pense que ça n'a pas été programmé
pour essayer de faire parler d'autre
chose que des taxis et du beurre
sinon ce serait ravi bon on pourra me
rappeler que j'ai eu quand même des des
appels les attentats terrorisme pendant
le ramadan et que là on assista en
tunisie ici il n'ya rien aussi une
mosquée au koweit on va peut-être
peut-être ans décédé dans des
circonstances
non je parle à skis ski pour répondre à
jean charles sur le sur le fichage
clairement si cette personne ne bouge
plus ne fait plus rien notamment celle
des fichiers sons il est jamais allé en
irak il est jamais l'ancien a priori des
informations cet imprévu
c'est pas quelqu'un qui a bougé qui
s'est radicalisée apparemment mais c'est
pas quelqu'un qui a bougé donc s'il fait
rien s'ils bougent pas s'il n'y a pas
d'élément il n'y a pas de raison de
continuer à
mais bon en fin 2008 certains ont
l'impression quand même qu'on est
beaucoup plus suivie sur l'année la
perte de ces pointes de permis de
conduire que sur ses allégeances celle
de complots l'extrême efficacité de la
police sur certains côtés immédiats
qu'elle ne fasse il ya 15 ans il a fait
ça mais là le type us à la fiche de
football c'est oracle a perdu je viens
car si tu t'interroges combien
accepteraient et sa face à ce terrorisme
on l'a déjà évoqué via boko haram dèche
c'est une forme de gangrène qu'on laisse
qu'on laisse prendre quand il perd tout
bon il n'y a pas de réellement il n'y a
pas de poussée science annoncé
impression que vous êtes tous entrain
dernier un concours milliards il n'y a
pas deux il n'y a pas de position
suffisamment non c'est pas une histoire
de complot pour moi mais je pense qu'il
ya pas de position suffisamment tranché
je pense effectivement justement à dire
bah je pars à boko haram par rapport à
des jeux sais pas j'ai l'impression que
les grands acteurs internationaux
devraient encore plus se positionner que
la communauté internationale devrait
encore plus régulière là on joue
j'ai l'impression quelques pas l'avenir
de l'humanité à terme quelque part c'est
ça en france
alors c'est vrai j'entendais à la radio
que le ramadan pouvais je pense que là
pour le coup c'est toute la communauté
musulmane qui doit ré expliquer le
message parce que le ramadan ça n'est en
rien ça c'est justement ce en un temps
de paix un temps d'apaisement un tendent
à 16 pour
se reconnecter avec les vraies valeurs
de la vie et méditer donc je pense
qu'aussi bien lecteur doit se
positionner mais bon il ya différents
dispositifs qui ont mis en place que
peut être également la communauté
musulmane pour réexpliquer le message
est que le salafisme se propage - je
pense qu'il ya vraiment quelque chose à
enrayer vite de cette offre
beaucoup de choses ont été dites et
c'est vrai que c'est un sujet complexe
je commencerai par dire que je suis
toujours terrifiés par les terroristes
tout à l'heure où terrorisme toujours
terrifié d'abord parce qu'il se passe ce
qui peut se passer dans les familles je
pense d'abord aux familles on vient de
l'apprendre il passé aujourd'hui on
vient de l'apprendre aussi bien en
france qu'en tunisie qu au koweit et je
suis toujours à me poser cette question
de lorsque ça arrive à l'extérieur de la
france ça passe comme une brève
ça passe comme quasiment seul un
événement d'information intel et elle
est proportionnelle au nombre de
kilomètres qui ne sais pas ça mais
lorsque ça me touche c'est juste que la
distance la distance est juste réduite
mais pour le coup on est beaucoup plus
la déflagration plus beaucoup plus
beaucoup plus importante
ça c'est pour dire que ton réalité c'est
un vrai programme je parlais pas de
paranoïa ou deux ou deux on a parlé de
valeurs de complot mais on l'a déjà dit
autour de cette table je pense - en
l'occurrence qui a une vraie stratégie
stratégie de ceux qui la mène
on parlait la dernière fois de ce soit
de boko haram ou que ce soit des des
groupes terroristes comme celui ci il ya
une vraie stratégie d'aller frapper à un
endroit où on peut diviser pour mieux je
dirais augmenter ses troupes pour faire
ça en france
pardon en france dans le monde l'idée
selon laquelle il ya elle il y aurait
plus d'un milliard de musulmans
auquel cas il y aura un groupuscule de
gens qui sont pour moi un peu le coup
dans la géostratégie qu'on a vraiment
affaire à des gens qui sont en train de
gérer une géographie et une stratégie
cette géographie c'est probablement
celle de l'état islamique qu'ils veulent
ce qui se revendique et qui veulent
essayer de s'accaparer mon jeu je serais
plutôt dans cette idée là qu'il ya une
vraie stratégie géographique de
commandes de s'accaparer un territoire
s'accaparer des on va dire une économie
et un vrai pouvoir
simplement ils sont pas nombreux il faut
augmenter les troupes au quelqu'un il ya
une stratégie pour faire partir des
djihadistes de france où des gens en
l'occurrence qui vont peupler et se
regrouper autour de ses armées mais en
plus envoyer des éléments qui pourraient
une fragilité tout ce qui pourrait nous
segmenté tout dans la société
occidentale j'parle pendant un an en
france aux quelques uns à ne pas se
désunir
on ne pourrait que servir cette
stratégie de qui leur permettrait de
grossir les rangs
et donc il ya une vraie volonté il ya
une vraie stratégie pour le coup j'ai
pas de jets pas d'avis sur la question
de la le coup de du complot il ya des
gens qui mène effectivement une
stratégie et suis encore écrit qui ont
des symboles
encore une fois les symboles de la
décapitation par exemple voilà ça j'en
suis je suis d'origine algérienne que
nous disait ton à l'époque
encore une fois on l'a déjà dit autour
de sept thèmes et que le dise était
encore à l'époque dans les années 80 8 9
10 en algérie où c'était par principe la
décapitation qui marquait le plus ses
esprits il ya eu jusqu'à 300 400 mille
morts en algérie sur des principes sur
les mêmes ou le terrorisme était une
arme celle face à des puissances puisque
finalement c'est fait on pourrait mettre
on pourrait abandonner l'armé nucléaire
on pourra abandonner tout ce qui protège
la nation avec des milliards mise sur la
sur la table pour essayer de se protéger
autrement mais il ya des choix on a fait
des choix de d'armement on a fait des
choix de combat on a fait des choix de
sécurisation va forcément mais pas
forcément à la réalité
d'où la stratégie de ceux qui veulent
combattre une idéologie dont je parlais
plus tôt deux plaques tectoniques et de
temps en temps effectivement ça bouge ça
bouge l'armé nucléaire
après c'est un autre débat il n'y a pas
que dice comme ennemi possible de nos
démocraties et d'occident la chine est
là aussi à les états unis fayat il ya un
nombre de pays qui s'entendent plus ou
moins bien que ses entendons plus ou
moins bien donc pas juste dire il faut
acheter des 4,4 pour les dans le désert
buts et boko haram ou des cheveux le
débat sur le nucléaire est ce que on est
en plein débat sur la loi sur la
sécurité et de renseignements qui
avaient peut-être pris un coup dans
l'aisne avec les écoutes américaines
enfin voilà c'est dit est-ce qu'on est
obligé d'aller de faire ce que font les
américains ce que voilà est-ce qu'on va
pas dépasser ce pourquoi ces lois sont
faites
est-ce que évidemment avec ce genre
d'attentât ça renforce ceux qui veulent
aller un petit peu plus loin dans le
renforcement de la sécurité et des
renseignements non florence façon la loi
a été votée débats le temps comme un
seul homme alors qu'elle a été votée le
lendemain de l'annoncé sur les écoutes
américaines rex a pas ça pas tellement
fragilisé le projet de loi et qui on a
les écoutes américaines on vote le
projet de loi et l'attentât donc on a
tous dans la même semaine
je veux dire en fonction des faits les
juges box variés wifi ce qui est
étonnant c'est que aux états unis
sont au contraire essayer de contenir un
peu les écoutes puisqu'ils ont revoté il
ya quoi il ya quinze jours trois
semaines
le patriot act qui venait à expiration
donc ils ont dû revoter le patriot act
ils ont fait en sorte de limiter
justement les écoutes pour qu'elles
soient moins générale est moins massive
et nous on va voter une loi qui est à la
limite un degré au dessus
le rapport à la loi à la nouvelle loi
américaine où on va voir nos plus de des
coupes massives et l'argent qu'on va
voir après derrière ce que dira le
conseil constitutionnel mais la toule et
où les parts du spécialiste du dos les
policiers ont l'air favorable ce genre
doit maintenant bon est-ce que ça va
est-ce que ça va permettre d'éviter ce
genre de juste là on voit bien que c'est
des gens et je suis désolé que ça existe
enfin je veux dire la loi ne fait que
légaliser des pratiques qui existent de
toute façon donc je suis pas certaine
dès lors que ça existe déjà mais moi je
pense qu'il y avait il ya eu une assez
grande naïveté et pour le coup il ya eu
de la manipulation aux femmes expulsion
discours politique mais c'est ça fait
partie du jeu sur ce texte qui est
plutôt un bon texte qui en effet a pour
mérite de place de mettre un peu de
règles là où qu'elle n'avait pas du tout
tout en sachant là encore de manière non
naïf que ces règles elles sont pas
peut-être pas fort franchement respecter
de manière scrupuleuse et alors sur les
coudes des chefs d'état par les états
unis
enfin là aussi fait une tempête dans un
beau livre
on découvre un truc on découvre quelque
chose que nous nous faisons et j'avais
parlé de cela il ya quelques années avec
un journaliste qui s'appelle jean
guisnel quevilly copié sur des cr et lui
disait défense mais vraiment tout le
monde le fait celui qui ne l'est pas il
a tort la seule règle c'est de ne pas se
faire prendre et la france est
d'ailleurs réputé pour le faire de
manière assez efficace notamment en
matière d'intelligence économique
alors ce qui est un peu plus troublant
dans ces histoires c'est quand on
apprend quand même que les allemands ont
écouté airbus industrie pour le matériel
là en revanche je trouve ça troublant
les côtes industrielle ce ne semble plus
dangereuse je crois que les écoute de
cet état où j'ai connu
oui pour collecter des informations qui
sont sans doute sans aucune chance aucun
intérêt mais ça va non c'est juste pour
rebondir sur les propos de jean charles
qui voudrais clore chaque discussion à
sa guise je continue à passer il ya un
gars moyen de réfléchir et pas rester
tout le temps dans gré des classes de
dettes voilà dans une pensée une pensée
à la fois unique et en même temps être
grave c'est vrai que les temps les temps
changent
je suis convaincu pour ma part qu'on
devrait peut-être mettre plus de moyens
sur finalement les armes de demain
c'est-à-dire le renseignement au
quelqu'un moi je souscris est ce que tu
disais à ce que vous disiez pardon c'est
vrai que finalement la veille du retour
en classe pourquoi exclure les
téléspectateurs donc voilà donc je
disais moi je considère qu'il ya des
moyens maintenant oui et payé va
s'adapter
je pense que l'argent mis dans le
renseignement et plus de sens
l'argent mis dans des combats de fin
d'année il convient quand des armes de
proximité aurait plus de sens inverse
pour moi je suis
nucléaires qui sont très onéreux et qui
probablement sont pas à l'échelle de des
vraies menaces
c'est juste c'est juste finma ble ment
pas les chaînes de la force des choses
mais c'est juste une manière de dire on
peut peut-être revoir les choses parce
qu'après tout c'est très émouvant
encore une fois la stratégie c'est l'art
de s'adapter à son environnement
l'environnement change
il est probablement qu'on aurait il
pensait mais c'est juste une
interrogation d'un spécialiste de
l'espace pcs de l'armement question mais
laurent socialement et juste regarde un
peu ce que font les chinois et comment
les chinois sarm et je commence comment
la chine bouge et tu verras que tu sois
pour faire un débat sur l'armement mais
sur le nucléaire le 15 mai c'est juste
une question c'est est rien c'est une
100 questions mais son état est ce qu on
a dévoyé adapté à notre véritable mets
au défi qui nous est imposé et c'est un
excellent une excellente passerelle pour
aller prendre sur le sujet qui nous
intéressera après qu'elle eut b risation
de la société c'est un passionné par ce
jeu mais en même temps j'ai cru que vous
allez nous dire une pérennisation du
terrorisme n'est pas faux c'est
qu'aujourd'hui les états unis ont une
avance considérable en matière de
technologie considérable et aujourd'hui
les américains sont en train de nouveau
de devenir les maîtres du monde
sur le plan politique sur le plan de la
défense et sur le plan marchand et ça
c'est le résultat d'années et d'années
de recherches dans la fameuse silicon
valley c'est aussi que les états unis
ont permis l'émergence de très grandes
sociétés comme apple ou microsoft et que
aujourd'hui grâce à des technologies sur
lesquelles ils ont pris une avance
considérable
ils contrôlent la planète et ça pour le
coup c'est dangereux et je vais vous
dire moi non sur l'enseignement bien
entendu mais non opinion sur le sujet si
je peux en avoir une évidemment mais
elle ne concerne que moi à titre
strictement personnel c'est que l'europe
n'a jamais été foutu de se mettre à la
hauteur des états unis pour avoir une
technologie
comparable alors que nous en avions les
moyens mais hélas nous n'avons pas mis
les moyens politiques pour le faire et
le résultat c'est que alors que nous
avions à la fois les moyens financiers
et surtout les compétences humaines pour
le faire nous n'avons jamais été ces
dernières années
c'est notamment ces dix dernières années
en capacité de mettre en face des
grandes puissances américaines ce qu'il
y avait lieu de mettre en place pour
lutter dans le domaine du renseignement
dans le domaine de l'armement mais aussi
dans le domaine marchand puisqu'on voit
qu'aujourd'hui quand nous parlons
d'hubert darby envy et de bien d'autres
puisque il ya une bonne trentaine d'
exemples de sociétés de même nature
ils ont fait le pouvoir absolu quand
vous voyez que nous souder comme hubert
aujourd'hui est coté en bourse à 40 dès
qu'on parle de ça oui mais comme ça à 42
milliards de dollars 1 42 milliard de
dollars pour hummer excusez moi c'est la
valorisation de france télécom
aujourd'hui c'est 1500 employés chez
hubert ses 160 milles c'est france
télécom
voilà à un moment donné il va bien
falloir quand même que le débat public
se met sur ces sujets qui sont en train
de transformer la planète à tel point
que si nous ne réagissons pas non pas au
niveau de la france
mais au niveau de l'europe on est fichu
dans les prix ailleurs au niveau de
l'europe en effet c'est mal parti vu ce
qui s'est passé à bruxelles dans la nuit
de jeudi à vendredi pour trouver un
accord sur des choses qui pourraient
paraître presque plus simple un mot
juste parce que je crois qu'on n'aura
pas le temps de parler du beurre
l'argent du beurre
il faut une réponse assez amusante
j'ai eu la chance qui est des gens qui
lisent mais pourquoi on me donne pas de
spécialité française soir était une
réponse qui est un peu un peu de classe
aux états unis aux écoutes des états
unis en un mot parce que je voudrais
qu'on parle d'un autre sujet à ces
mythes comme en amour il ya aucune
raison de lui accorder quoi que ce soit
je n'ai pas menacé de mort il n'est pas
il vient pas d'un pays qui soit une
dictature il n'est pas en dessous
maintenant il nommé départ il est pas en
danger ce sont le seul truc c'est qu'il
a accusé de viol en suède
pour l'instant je sais ça me paraît
léger comme raison pour le d'accueillir
ici a poursuivi par les nazis c'est pas
parce que tu es poursuit par les états
unis sont une démocratie c'est pas grave
non ils risquent pas certains disent
aurait été une réponse comme ça assez
amusante que vous mangez pas beaucoup de
pain et qui faisait un peu moi je
préfère vous accueille environ un mille
grande plus un vrai qu'il est vraiment
dans la merde que julian assange
honnêtement je vais crier à mes grandes
plus à nonu pas les états unis non mais
ce n'est pas pour moi mon but n'est pas
de là dessus il vous allez vous en
parlez vous en fichez non c'est génial
accueilli je moi je
pour l industrie l habiter ici obama on
sent que la latence
ils appellent la france est très
vigilant qu'il appelle la france à
regarder les choses de plus près on a
l'impression qu'il ya un regard tourné
vers la france voire mieux
j'ai le sentiment qu'ils prépareraient
éventuellement quelque chose pour servir
la france c'est à ça que je pense bien
sûr je n'ai probablement pas le moment
que jean chambre on en reparlera si on
parlait du ber et des taxis alors hop
c'est dire de ceux qui font covoiturage
qui n'ont pas des chauffeurs
professionnels
uba d'autres chauffeurs qui sont des
chauffeurs professionnels contre les
taxis contre lesquels des taxis sont pas
contents mais enfin ceux contre lesquels
il n'y a pas d'action juridique là
françois hollande a dit ce matin même
que les aider les voitures de ses
chauffeurs seraient saisis donc que le
gouvernement est prêt à aller jusqu'au
bout pour faire respecter la loi
qu'est ce qui vous a frappé dans ce
conflit est ce que c'est pas devant la
violence peut-être est-ce que c'est le
fait que y ait d'un côté d'illégalité et
puis de l'autre des taxis qui sont un
peu aux abois est ce que c'est le débat
entre le libéralisme d'un côté et
peut-être des gens qui sont trop taxé de
l'autre qu'est ce qui vous intéresse aux
débats il ya plusieurs angles pourra
pour aborder ce sujet je vais prendre
celui ci j'espère que l'on voudra pas
mais c'est celui ci qui m'intéresse en
l'occurrence et les professions
réglementées c'est plus ça qui
m'interpelle moissac s'il n'y aurait pas
de sujet si on les rembourser tous deux
leur plaque de taxi en gros tout ce qui
avait un taxi à 100 millions 200 mille
euros
si on les rembourser demain matin je
pense que le sujet serait pas là du tout
il faut il faut il faut explique hélène
deux cent mille euros c'est un marché
intérieur aux taxis c'est pas le coût
d'une licence ses côtes consiste à
revendre entre eux parce que simplement
il ya un numerus clausus sein qui
empêcha qui empêche aux autres
d'installer simplement moi j'ai connu le
taxi j'ai connu encore une fois au
travers des gens que je fréquente des
gens qui sont là qui sont pas en
capacité d'avoir une start up ou d'avoir
une grosse entreprise ou pour
d'allemands de même de trouver un boulot
ont décidé de se lancer dans les taxis
geisha ils ont baissé d'abord ils ont
bossé ce qu'il faut passer à une
certaine époque s'il n'y avait pas il
n'y avait pas les une formation et à
l'information fallait prendre une ombre
huit mois qu'ils ont bossé
ensuite il fallait acheter la licence
une fois qu'on a fait tout ça on se sent
chefs d'entreprise on a ça me tue et on
travaille et d'un seul coup vous avez un
un système pas forcément en cause encore
une fois mais c'est cette idée selon
laquelle voilà il ya des gens qui sont
capables de prendre une voiture demain
et d'avoir une possibilité en
concurrence pour le pour eux déloyale de
faire le même métier tel de conduire des
gens moyennant une rémunération bas donc
c'est ça finalement le fond du sujet
parce que ces mecs là s'ils étaient
remboursés du fait de leur plaque
je pense qu'ils prendraient hubert tout
de suite et il ferait de la même façon
il ya le fait aussi que enfin les
conducteurs du père pops sûr quand même
alors là moi si je peux dire non mais ce
que je veux dire c'est que si demain
c'est les taxis étaient remboursés leur
plaque tout le monde rentrerait dans un
système finalement qui sera à peu près
identique mais on y mettrait des règles
du tout j'ai de mettre des règles
beaucoup plus importante parce qu'on
considère qu' on est dans une
concurrence déloyale
auquel cas il ya des règles
supplémentaires mais si demain elle
aimait rire au même niveau à mon sens y
aurait il y aurait moins de sujets par
contre à quoi ça me fait penser à ça me
fait penser qu'il ya d'autres
professions réglementées
on peut penser à la pharmacie par
exemple avec des numerus clausus avec
des implantations sur le territoire de
façon géographique et la même façon pour
imaginer que demain il peut y avoir une
version telle promesse numérisation du
système donc en fait c'est en valais
parlera peut-être après le 2 mai je
n'arrêtais rappelé annie l'angle sur
lequel ses frères ont dit que des gros
clients d hubert pops et notamment les
étudiants parce que voilà il est osé
trouver facilement et c'est moins cher
bah un gros client et je pense même un
des grands fournisseurs parce que
au-delà de ces faux ça prolonge un peu
ce que disait mustapha sait on se
retrouve un peu un clivage entre ceux
qui ont du travail et ceux qui n'en
n'ont pas parce que qui conduit les
clients d'hubert ceux qui n'ont pas de
travail
il ya beaucoup de chômeurs qui font ça
les gens pour avoir la chance d'être en
compliments ou même des jeunes combien
sont les gens qui ont fait des études
qui ont des masters et qui sont au
chômage aujourd'hui faut bien faire
quelque chose faut bien manger l'argent
tombe pas du ciel
donc c'est aussi un moyen comme un autre
donc nous ça nous permet de nous
déplacer à moindre coût et ça peut nous
permettre également de gagner de
l'argent alors j'entends bien le
désarroi deux de ses chauffeurs de taxi
qui ont un pays qui se sont endettés sur
10 20 ans pour certains
alors surveillez envahissante et qui
malheureusement arrivent pas à faire
leurs chiffres et qui se disent mais
comment je vais faire mais c'est vrai
que d'un autre côté pour ceux qui n'ont
pas d'argent pour ceux qui n'ont pas de
travail c'est aussi une voie de solution
c'est le principe des ruptures
technologiques
moi je me souviens de la règle à calcul
j'ai passé mon bac et qu'une règle à
calcul j'imagine le type qui faisait les
règles à calcul à l'époque et qui se
faisait caves et des industries qui la
calculette est arrivé le lendemain il
affirmé je pourrais donner des exemples
comme ça de rupture technologique ou des
industries des pans entiers de la
technologie ancienne est tombé devant
une donnée c'est vrai qu'il ya un
élément technologie interne et la
rupture
ensuite y'a pas simplement rupture il ya
aussi l'idée qu' il ya des contrats de
travail et des choses qui protège sauf
que la protection parfois qui est
important de saison on en a suffisamment
parlé autour de cette table des charges
sociales et de la protection sociale
simplement il ya des gens qui les met en
concurrence directe et on revient encore
à cette idée qu'ont développé la
dernière fois sur sept un peu sept
comédiens l'intermittence du travail
d'une part et puis l'hypocrisie de tous
c'est à dire que tout le monde va au
mieux disant tout le monde vend au prix
et on ne voit par les conséquences de
nos propres actes je pourrais la grande
distribution versus le petit commerce
je pourrais parler de lui parce que les
taxis ces internats blement ils achètent
des choses tout le monde va ouvrir très
clairement donné c'est très compliqué et
lé premier quota à l'époque où moi je
prenais encore des taxis
ils sont les premiers à dia bâ la
musique c'est génial je télécharge
gratuitement vous êtes un abruti vue
continue à acheter ses disques
on a tous des contradictions
bon après un combat le truc est un peu
curieux c'est ce débat avec durée des
chauffeurs professionnels des chauffeurs
professionnels je vois pas la différence
entre professionnels et non
professionnels justement à
l'impressionnant légalement les digues
ne connaissent pas la connaissent pas
plus par ic n'importe qui il n'y a plus
un chauffeur de taxi qui pourraient
travailler son gps ça n'existe mais la
différence entre hubert et hubert peuple
et le service super pop est quand même
assez différent parce que dans sur
hubert les chauffeurs hummer ils ont ils
doivent fournir un casino d'issia la
raison de formation ils font ça ils ne
font que ça mais ils sont en auto
entrepreneur sur les vtc donc ils sont
parfaitement carré par rapport à la
techno voilà là ils sont des auto
entrepreneurs
ils n'ont pas acheté de l'essence mais
il bison d'autres raids et puis c'est
encadré par la loi thévenoud le jour où
il sortira droit de retenir au jour le
jour où la loi sortira du conseil
constitutionnel est en revanche le
service hubert pops et trois clics on
est chauffeur pas de quasiment de rien
n'y a pas d'assurance il développa tard
pour transporter on n'est pas assuré
pour transporter et les gens en général
c'est peu c'est pas grand chose c'est
des rémunérations assez faible et qui ne
sont pas qu'ils sont pas déclarés donc
on a déjà deux décisions il a une
décision du tribunal correctionnel de
paris qui dès du mois d'octobre
2014 dont hubert a fait appel parce que
hubert a été bercé toute façon ils
gagnent du temps c'est parfait a fait
appel de cette décision qui était sur
des pratiques commerciales mensongère
parce qu'on fait hubert vendait au
départ le service une belle frappe en
disant c'est du covoiturage alors que
c'est du transport de taxi afin de bien
c'est donc là ils ont été condamnés à
100000 euros d'amande et ils ont
interjeté appel de cette décision
après on va voir aussi ce que va dire le
conseil constitutionnel sur tes genoux
qui interdit justement ces services là
et ensuite hubert a été condamné aussi
par le tribunal de californie
et ça c'est beaucoup plus grave et
hummer oui c'est beaucoup d'afro riber
parce que en californie qui le premier
marché c'est sur son talent et c'est le
premier marché du verre le tribunal de
californie a condamné il ya une semaine
ou dix jours
hubert en dix ans les chauffeurs sont
des salariés donc en requalifiant en
contrat de travail
le et donc ça ça peut mettre ça et ça
c'est extrême système tout le système
est cru tout le modèle économique
d'hubert tombe parce que c'est un
million de chauffeurs donc si ça devient
un million de salariés
c'est plus du tout le même schéma
économique est là il ya sont plus en
danger je pense pour le moment sur ce
terrain là au niveau de la décision de
californie parce qu'après ça peut faire
une traînée de tout est ici fait savoir
il suffit qu'ils des chauffeurs entre
guillemets hubert ou hubert pop qui
viennent dire mais en fait un lien de
subordination et que certains arrivent à
prouver le lien de subordination et tout
va être qualifié en contrat de travail
par les conseils des problèmes de france
donc là il ya un véritable enjeu sur le
modèle économique d'hubert par rapport à
cette décision je lui je vous laisse la
parole d'abord que voilà sur ce conflit
qu'est ce que tu me sembles le voyez
vous quand je vois te prêter un peu au
delà de la question des taxis ou viens
d'en parler c'est sur sept jours joint
les propos de florence sur cette
économie dite collaborative qui fait que
beaucoup de gens ces merveilles de ce
truc là dix neuf à l'économie quand
c'est sympa parce que on va créer des
écosystèmes dans lesquels on il ya plus
de consommateurs et plus de producteurs
mais on est tous un peu consommateur est
un peu producteurs
amazon fait un truc du genre ouzou dit
le tient en sortant du travail vous
pourriez pas porter le colis à son
destinataire parce que vous êtes à côté
parce que vous êtes à côté c'est sur
votre chemin et le fonds aux états unis
pour 2 $ de l'heure au maximum ça c'est
le c'est le taux le plus élevé en
attendant évidemment amazon fait ses
choux gras de ce2 ce2 ce système là en
écoutant florence tout à l'heure aussi
je repensais aux déclarations de jacques
attali la semaine dernière qui disait
qu'au fond son modèle le modèle d'avenir
c'était l'intermittent du spectacle et
que et que le salariat ne serait
désormais réservé qu'à une élite leur
extrêmement exception d'exception et que
m et qu'il fallait s'en réjouir parce
que chacun pourrait désormais prendre en
main son destin
moi c'est pas le modèle vers lequel je
tendrais naturellement mes jeux
on parle d'une économie du partage moi
je vois plutôt là le partagent des
miettes ou des quelques miettes qui
réside
c'est à dire que c'est aussi les plus
pauvres ce que disait un peu c'est vrai
ça attire aussi des gens qui n'ont pas
de boulot pas ailleurs qui ont besoin de
nous joindre les deux bouts de voilà
donc c'est une exploitation aussi des
plus faibles de terres de l'exploitation
j'en sais rien parce que c'est ma part
qu'est ce qu'ils valent rien ou sa jeune
talent mais ce que je vois c'est qu'en
face les produits qui sont révocables et
remarques site passe comme ça ça fleure
bon un peu mais mais mais face à cela il
ya des profits énormes way qui sont
rayés des profits énormes et on a bien
une évolution la du modèle social et du
contrat de travail parce que là on voit
bien ce sont des gens qui vont accumuler
des heures pour arriver à faire tant
d'heures par semaine qu'on n'est pas
avec un contrat avec tendeur c'est on va
real et piqué à droite à gauche des
heures pour les accumuler et faire son
il aligne un prêt à beaucoup de travail
et quand de l'autre côté on propose de
passer aux 32 heures
c'est fabuleux ça ça on va parler
peut-être tout à l'heure parce que c'est
mais jean les petits bouts
mais cela dit je la lis cela dit en gros
tout le monde est à peu près d'accord me
freine pas vrai on ne freine pas le
poids comme on n'a pas freiné les
machines à vapeur le moteur à explosion
l'aviation enfin le téléphone la
télévision c'est le progrès donc ce que
stéphane appelle tout à l'heure
l'économie collaborative effectivement
rentrera dans les moeurs
ce qui moi mes frais c'est que il faut
attendre que les taxis se foutent sur la
figure avec les vtc ou avec humour que
d'un seul coup on découvre que oh là là
il ya un problème on est en train de
révolutionner le monde marchand sauf que
ça fait dix ans avec la technologie
numérique et l'émergence de ce qu'on
appelle le commerce digital que on sait
très bien que la révolution on n'a pas
devant nous elle est là maintenant donc
et elle a hébergé réellement depuis
environ c'est interdit c'est bien ce qui
fait que personne n'a de vraies réponses
quand même ce qu'elle est devant nous et
les ai les larmes là où moi je suis
révolté c'est que il est du rôle des
politiques et des organisations
professionnelles dans tous les domaines
que d'éclairer le chemin de la société
vous connaissez mon avis sur le problème
français qui est l'absence des corps
intermédiaires en paille à venir mais en
même temps si nous étions suffisamment
éclairé
probablement que nous ne serions pas
aujourd'hui à regarder en témoins les
violences perpétrées par le groupe
basque armé l'a aimée résultats estime
trop tard le gouvernement aurait dû être
fermées
non la loi tvo est inapplicable tout le
monde sait et en plus tu es venu ne
concerne que les taxis alors que tous
les domaines d'activité ou presque sont
impactés
donc à un moment donné moi je dis ce qui
se passe aujourd'hui dans la violence
c'est dommage mais là ça se passera par
faire vous le comprenez non je les
comprends pas mais en même temps c'est
comme ça c'est comme ça mais qu'est ce
que vous voulez ces types là n'ont pas
d'autres moyens de se faire entendre que
d'aller dans la violence
dommage en même temps c'est dans la
culture française depuis la nuit des
temps c'est comme ça maintenant on
voulait revenir pour terminer
voudrais simplement dire ceci nos
politiques quelle que soit leur couleur
d'ailleurs pas plus que nous
représentations officielles n'ont vu
venir
uno pris conscience de la réalité d'une
révolution majeure que nous sommes en
train de vivre maintenant
alors je demande simplement et c'est un
message que j'envoie c'est pas un
principe comme ça arrêté jeudi
il faut que les personnels politiques et
que les organisations professionnelles
prennent conscience que nous vivons
actuellement une révolution majeure dans
tous les domaines de la société et en
particulier dans le domaine marchand
ça va transcender considérablement à
sauter occidentale mais les chinois et
l'ensemble d'ailleurs du continent sud
est asiatique et en fin de compte de
l'avant sur nous et donc si nous ne
prenons pas les mesures maintenant pour
permettre sa marque alors les mesures
c'est d'abord de poser sur la table la
réglementation qui aujourd'hui fait que
vous avez ce que ea non il ne veut venir
ma part oui ils le font trop tard ils le
font trop tard mustapha disait à juste
titre il faut rembourser les licences
taxi bien sûr qu'il faut le faire lui
milliards d'accord ça faisait avant
c'est parce que on trouve tout
impossible qu on avance plus on ne bouge
plus dans les résultats des courses on
se fout sur la figure on est en train
d'avoir des confins des comportements
violents racistes non on n'est que sont
des taxis qui balancent des dvd ou des
draps lui et dont le charisme de
caricaturer pas des gens dit à la gueule
des gens qui sont dans la justice
moi je suis je suis dans le domaine de
l'hôtellerie et de la restauration je
peux vous dire que les hôteliers sont
toujours aujourd'hui autant impacté que
les textes raison mais bien sur dix ans
mais jean charest on ne peut pas avoir
un débat on ne peut pas avoir un débat
de cette nature ce débat-là ne sert à
rien mais l'inversé est aussi des
maisons
airbnb les maisons ce qui est important
c'est quoi c'est de se dire simplement
que à un moment donné il faut que nos
responsables politiques et nos
représentations professionnelles est une
vraie vision sur l'avenir et que nous
nous préparions aux modifications que
nous devons avoir ça passe par la
réglementation il faut la changer
ça passe pour nos comportements il faut
les changer on peut pas être en
permanence à vouloir tout moins cher et
moins cher et se dit avec
il va aller quand même parce qu'à un
moment donné quand l'argent ne circule
plus et qui a plus d'argent il se passe
quoi tout le monde est dans la précarité
donc si on ne veut pas ça pour nos
enfants et nos petits enfants il est
temps de bouger nos fesses voilà c'est
tout là dessus au travers élément c'est
que moi j'ai l'impression que ça
fonctionne bien au moins pour ceux qui
l'ont mis en place parce que ça donne le
sentiment qu'il ya plein de gens qui
s'agitent et il ya une entreprise qui
siphonnent par le haut quelqu'un non
seulement ça précarisent les gens les
acteurs mais en plus ça si fun cet
argent qui lui n'est pas fiscalisée voir
repartir et dans des paradis fiscaux ou
quelqu'un ça serait donc la question que
je pose c il n'y a pas moyen mettre un
système à la française concurrents en
gros c'est réfléchissant sur des
systèmes adaptés concurrentiel a posé
des questions mais au moins tu roules
aggravé à savoir dont vous allez faire
un hubert français c'est ça non mais un
grenier français encore une fois il ya
il ya un modèle qui a été et qui a été
avancé par hubert ça me paraît pas est
extraordinairement compliquée que
d'imaginer des choses
cela libère enfin je pense qu'elle est
traitée en échange je pense surtout à
cette idée selon laquelle l'argent
serait siphonner sur le territoire
français et irait dans les paradis
fiscaux probablement sont des
entreprises fiscalité différente
au moins ça resterait sur son territoire
ça ne règle pas le problème
je parle parle essentiellement
américaines je n'ai pas le zinc
essentiellement américaines il ya des
sujets vous savez c'est le grand
principe du data systems
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire
qu'aujourd'hui vous avez quel âge il
considéra en garde ce sont les
américains qui détiennent tous à mes
amis enfin coûte quand vous parlez du
ber quand vous parlez de tripadvisor de
booking de trivago
et c'est tout ça c'est sûr des boîtes
américaines et nous avons nous la
capacité de pouvoir lutter contre ça à
l'échelon européen
non si l'europe sera sans nous avons la
capacité d'en faire autoriser profit
leur ensemble
roblin c'est bah oui non mais sur les
berges si on les taxe penser qu'on va
pouvoir arrêter finalement nous l'avons
nous préférions pas fait le travail sur
les taxis je pense qu'il ya quand même
une solution par rapport à leur licence
lui dire quand on a supprimé la
profession d'avoué
les avoués z'avaient des charges et dans
le cadre de la suppression de la
position des bruits qui sont devenus
avocats et vous l'impression d'avoir
c'était les gens qui avaient le monopole
sur les cours d'appel de représentation
sur les sur les cours d'appel
téléchargement éclairage voulait dire
que ouais c'est quand j'ai vu que
j'avais un procès n'étant pourtant du
maroc vers saint aignan un procès la
cour d'appel de versailles j'ai été
obligé de jouer à la cour d'appel à la
cour d'appel de versailles
voilà cette profession a été supprimée
quand ils ont supprimé la profession de
dédommager les amis il a fallu des
dommages est désavoué parce que c'était
en été quand j'ai la charge
malin et donc il ya eu ils ont bien
trouver un système pour les dédommager
donc pourquoi est-ce qu'on réfléchisse
aux problèmes avec les dockers
aujourd'hui défaut le dossier je vous
montre se décident de finir comment on
reconnaît un taxi là vous avez le le
taxi anglais le texte in rio qui dieu et
le taxi français nous avons ces 22 qu'on
donne à voilà ça a été très très bon
dessin 2d ligne dans cette ville qui
s'appelle ep taxi c'est vrai que parce
que ce que vous disiez stéphanois ce à
quoi on assiste aussi c'est ce que ce
que jean-luc c'est aussi un champ non
changement de société quoi changement
d'économie en tout cas est-ce qu'on peut
prôner ça c'est qu'on peut résister est
ce que c est ce que c'est par débat au
fond en trop souiller le libéralisme pur
et dur parce que b repop c'est un peu ça
c'est des gens qui payent pas qui
s'installe ce sont 11 passes et 2
deux informations sans payer de charges
etc c'est réellement finalement par la
technologie
d'autres voire sur le quotidien pas
seulement d'ailleurs dans le domaine
marchand aussi dans la communication
regardez sur canal rigolo quand il
présente les guignols et 10 bienvenue
sur l'ancêtre de internet ligne bon
voilà ça signifie bien ce que ça veut
dire ça veut dire qu'aujourd'hui
internet qui je vous le rappelle est
détenu par les américains partis google
sergey ces américains et aujourd'hui
tout un hangar transformé
regardez la formation là nous sommes
vendredi nous avons été informés de
l'attentât il y a deux heures à peu près
ou trois heures et d'un seul coup nous
avons grâce à internet les informations
au fur et à mesure tout de suite alors
qu' il ya encore cinq ans c'était
impossible donc ça transforme
considérablement notre quotidien il faut
tenir compte on ne reviendra pas en
arrière il ya quelques années le premier
ministre aurait pu aller voir un match
de foot se connaissent pas mais voilà
tout va tellement vite donc il faut
vraiment que nous ayons la capacité
maintenant maintenant nous notre
génération et je parle pour ces fera
bien entendu qui est la plus jeune
d'entre nous de lui permettent d'avoir
un avenir plus serein parce que là moi
j'aurai l'âge de ces forages et peur
d'anglais et j'ai peur oui j'ai peur
là j'ai peur pour elle un sens qui donc
travaillent à nous les anciens voilà
notre travail à nous les anciens c'est
de permettre à ces fera et à ses enfants
de pouvoir avoir un avenir qui soit plus
serein et et est prêt un peu plus
prévisible qui ne l'est aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui on selon ansa l'accord doit
alors j'ai pas peur mais je suis
consciente du fait qu'aujourd'hui le cdc
du loup pis on signe un cd
on est très très très très très heureux
quand bien même le les tâches auxquelles
on serait proposée ne nous ne nous
plairait pas j'ai conscience qu'il y
aura pas de retraite va falloir
travailler tout vous longtemps on en a
conscience
c'est non mais sur la mer de travailler
sur son nombre de mes amis qui ont tous
des masters qui ont fait hec sciences-po
pour d'autres qui sont au chômage
on a conscience que maintenant les
études ne sont même plus un passeport
suffisant pour être sûr d'obtenir un
travail stable
oui disons quand même qu'elles
permettent plus d'avoir un travail que
le seul qui n'ont pas fait d'études
il ya quand même un gap important enfin
il faut quand même leurs souliers à
chaque fois parce que c'est une garantie
comme ça c'est plus une garantie non
c'est pas un travail assuré mais il ya
moins de chômage il ya moins de chômage
c'est des gens qui ont fait des études
que des gens qui n'ont pas fait il faut
quand même le rappeler parce que sinon
c'est surtout qu'on partage plus
simplement sur le territoire français
avant dans l'impression que en france
ont partagé le travail qui était en
france entre français aujourd'hui le
travail en france est partageable sur
toute la planète donc on a à la fois des
délocalisations voir des entreprises sur
la france qui sont faites par d'autres
donc on sent bien que tout se partage sa
salle et tout ce mondial il ya de moins
en moins mais pour ceux qui restent il
ya pire que ça à mon avis et c'est pour
ça que je pense bull soit assez fort à
sa génération c'est que lorsque nous
avons inventé notre la machine à vapeur
mais moment où on a commencé à
l'industrie il s'est passé 50 ans nous
être le moment où on a inventé le moteur
à explosion et le moment 1 la voiture
est devenue un bien à populaire il s'est
passé 70 ans entre le moment il va
maintenant c'est l'avion et le moment où
on a transporté 100 ou 200 personnes
dans un avion il s'est passé 60 à la
entre le moment où la vie est une
accélération des entrées mise en place
les le commerce digital est en train de
d'imprégner nos vies quotidiennes
il s'est passé cinq ans voilà et donc le
rythme est sacrément différents
par conséquent nous devons nous notre
génération en tenir compte est conscient
de ça et arrêter de faire l'autruche ce
que font hélas beaucoup de nos amis le
rythme et la démographie de plus en plus
nombreux et vous partagez justement
un mot puisque vous parliez tout à
l'heure de christiane taubira tout cas
dit elle a pas d elle a pas se faire un
projet politique wallonie je rêve d'une
société où pourraient travailler trois
heures par jour salvaza vous avez l'air
de vous sembler totalement aberrant et
mon bon mais je vois pas en quoi c'est
une solution alors on a on a choisi de
passer sur un format 35 heures en disant
comme ça on va créer d'emplois est-ce
que de l'emploi a été créé et est ce que
ça a été une solution non j'ai pas
l'impression
donc je vois pas rabaisser les prenez si
vous prenez les courbes à long terme il
ya une un parallèle total entre la
baisse du temps de travail et le plein
emploi
évidemment après on en parle mal parce
qu'on n'en parle par la loi on a imposé
les 35 heures par la loi mais la baisse
du temps de travail entre la baisse du
temps de travail et le plein au point il
ya un parallèle au final revient bien
plus grave que ça je 35 heures c'était
une catastrophe 32 ce sera encore pire
parce que on est on est ça le d35 avons
complètement dévalorisé l'idée qu'on
pouvait s'éclater dans son travail c'est
à dire qu'on est placée sous de fausses
sociétés de loisirs
on a dit aux gens sont très animées au
35 ans mais si on en dix ans le boulot -
vous en faites plus vous aurez le temps
de faire autre chose donc ce n'est
surtout pas dans le boulot qu'ils font
ce qu'il faut c'est pas nous ce qui est
absolument dramatique parce que du coup
je veux dire non pour de son siècle les
salariés français sont les plus
productrices on ne peut pas le temps
réel le temps réel aux états 10 et 30 à
moi le soir en allemagne sur 31 heures
parce que dans son boulot parce qu'on
parle de travail à plein temps mais pas
du travail à plein temps ils vont nous
entendre taubira dire c'est très bien
pour aller à la plage est livrée chez
moi je suis assez frappé qu'on veuille
pas ouvrir jamais ouvrir ce débat sous
prétexte que il ya eu en effet une loi
qui était ridicule sur des 35 heures
parce que c'est ça procède et d'en haut
et c'était pas comme ça il fallait
procéder mais mais mais l'idée de d'été
de la réduction du temps de travail en
soi n'est pas totalement ridicule lui
sont faites
mais que derrière c'est que le travail
c'est bien ses biens personnels réseau
bien donc pour ces biens veut en faire
le moins possible qu'on ait laissé
filtrer que c'était peut être aussi
forte sur autre chose que le travail est
pas évidente on est par exemple on était
avocat mais messieurs je pouvais être
avocat seulement une heure par jour ce
serait merveilleux parce que je pense
que peut-être un peu dommage peut-être
que florence est contente de travailler
son travail d'intérêt
j'espère que cette ville 32 eur et ready
est ce que la question c'est pas de dire
pourquoi est-ce qu'on doit fixer une
durée du travail est ce qu'on peut pas
dire dans chaque entreprise parce que la
durée du travail dans l'entreprise x y
ou z n'est pas forcément la même y'a pas
peut-être pas forcément le plan de
charge dans les landes 9h30
non mais dire dans chaque entrée légal
est innocent que ça dure et le travail
en fonction du travail que voilà de la
production de ce qu'on n'a pas la même
chose dans une usine dans un dans une
société il n'y a que des consultants il
n'y a pas la même durée du travail a pas
le même investissement
donc plutôt que de dire tout le monde à
35 heures où tout le monde à 32 ou
toulouse auxerre 9
il ya peut-être une question dans son
plan de 50 ans et des louages et dans
les vallons
est-ce qu'on peut pas aussi déjà sur
certaines entreprises et puis après les
gens pour les heures sup ça rejoint sais
mais bon on est à 32 parce que j'ai
entreprises qui peuvent dire bah oui non
moi en fait si tout le monde je peux
avoir tué plus de monde tout le monde à
30 heures ou à je ne sais pas il ya
toujours sur quoi être à voir en quoi
s'accrocher à cette à durer toujours un
gros mépris des gens qui nous gouvernent
pour pour le pour le peuple bas peuple
aux anglais il faut prendre il faut
arrêter de travailler sur surtout à
gauche il dit c'était faut prendre un
amant s'était il faut arrêter de
travailler à 58 59 60 ans maximum les
gens qui nous proposent et sandales et
77 ministre depuis 40 ans maintenant on
nous dit il faut bosser 32 heures par
semaine par des gens qui sont censés
booster 90 heures par semaine en tout
cas c'est ce que veut nous faire comme
madame taubira
donc pourquoi est-ce que ce qu'elle
propose aux hôtels ne l'appliquent pas
elle qu'elle soit bini cependant avant
15 heures de m6 sera aussi l'idée de
réduire le chômage en fin de l'heure
mais c'est toujours ses grands projets
de société les gens sans explosant c'est
pour les autres épreuves au pot pour les
gens font moins intéressant pour les
ricains développement à 5 min sans
l'ajout au barbican
mais c'est méprisable ancien auditeur
par exemple en tout cas ce week-end et
on travaille en consignant amis et
clients un grand coup à la notion de
valeur du travail que clairement et
jean-charles là dessus ça à raison
certains
moi je vis dans un univers sera le même
que le vôtre moi mon univers à moi soit
environ un million de salariés quand
même dans le domaine de l'hôtellerie et
de la restauration je peux vous assurer
qu'à partir du moment où nous avons été
soumis à la réglementation sur la
réduction du temps de travail
ça a changé considérablement les
comportements donc moi je suis pas une
minute pardon je suis pas défavorable à
l'arrêt du travail à condition qu'on
leur ait organise mais il faut le
réorganiser de façon sensée par des
coordinations à l'intérieur même de
l'ensemble des secteurs habités et le
nôtre arrestation il parle même plus de
la mia ou que ceux du modem femme là
dessus et puis non il faut pouvoir
parler de tout lancer des débats sur
actuellement et puis il faut laisser
venir les idées et puis ne pas ne pas
mettre le charrue idéologique de parle
de ça on a l'impression qu'ils veulent à
leur travail machin des autres a déjà
fait ça travailler plus pour gagner plus
sans fin sympa mieux marché semble t-il
mais parlons de tout il faut il faut
voir nous avons à leur offrir
l'enfer est pavé de bonnes intentions
baisser le temps de travail s'était pas
trouvé peut créer plus d'emplois
s'étaient partagés l'emploi sauf que la
première des techniques dans une
entreprise c'est d'augmenter la
productivité au quelqu'un on baisse le
nombre d'heures travaillées on augmente
la productivité et sa neutralisent tout
le monde
la vraie question c'est de savoir sk 32
on aura les moyens d'une productivité
accentuée au quelqu'un on se relève et
va vers un plus grand partage
c'est la question mais moi je rejoins
sur deux ans florence à raison de deux
heures par semaine mais non mais juste
que florence a raison il a travaillé de
la productivité v la productivité la
date retenue par autre chose que par le
travail humain enfin c'est bien
maintenant
générateur par l'humain et par la
machine par machine qui sont américaines
merci merci à tous les six ont des
raisons et raison 400 sur ce plateau
parce que il faisait un peu frais c'est
donc en cette fin du show pendant toute
l'émission
merci à tous et on se retrouve dans 15
jours